Combien de temps
ça vous prendrait
de lire 20 LIVRES ?
C’est pas l’affaire de cinq minutes…
En plus,
des références de culture générale
INCONTOURNABLES
ce ne sont pas
des livres de cent pages,
et puis si vous lisez
pour RETENIR
des choses,
alors vous devez prendres des notes,
ce qui prend
ENCORE PLUS DE TEMPS…
Vous m’avez compris :
lire les vingt ouvrages
dont je vais vous parler,
ça serait très long
— ça vous prendrait un an,
je pense,
SI vous êtes très sérieux…
Donc abandonnez l’idée :
n’achetez pas ces livres,
ne les ouvrez pas.
Regardez simplement cette vidéo
jusqu’au bout
en prenant des notes :
vous allez gagner
ÉNORMÉMENT
de temps.
Regarder cette vidéo suffira
pour vous faire
une BONNE IDÉE
de ce qu’il y a
dans les livres de la liste
parce que j’ai lu,
et même parfois résumé,
la plupart de ces livres
— donc j’en comprends bien
les idées essentielles.
Et puis surtout,
le but,
ce n’est pas de vous cultiver,
mais de réussir un exercice précis :
LA DISSERTATION.
Bah oui,
c’est à ÇA
que vont vous servir
les vingt références.
Je les ai sélectionnées
POUR ÇA :
elles servent à défendre
des idées IMPORTANTES
dans les grands thèmes de culture générale
des concours administratifs.
C’est pour ça que ce sont
des références TRÈS RENTABLES :
elles pourront vous servir
dans beaucoup de dissertations.
Alors,
les références,
c’est bien,
mais c’est LA MÉTHODOLOGIE
qui fait la différence
en dissertation.
Ça tombe bien,
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut :
un cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation.
Vous pouvez le recevoir
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo.
Inscrivez-vous,
et vous m’en direz des nouvelles.
Mon introduction est déjà longue,
donc j’abrège.
Je vais bien sûr vous donner
la liste des références,
mais je vais aussi préciser
l’UTILITÉ
de chaque référence
pour une dissertation
aux concours administratifs
— c’est-à-dire CE QUE la référence sert à montrer
dans une argumentation —
et puis je résumerai aussi
très rapidement
les idées essentielles de
chaque livre.
Si vous estimez que
D’AUTRES références
méritent de figurer dans ma liste,
ou si vous avez
D’AUTRES IDÉES de listes,
n’hésitez pas à me le dire
dans les commentaires.
Voilà voilà,
je vous enfin ai dit
tout ce que je voulais vous dire.
Regardez bien la vidéo jusqu’au bout,
et vous allez gagner
ÉNORMÉMENT
de temps.
1ère référence : La République, Platon
C’est peut-être le livre le plus célèbre de
la philosophie occidentale, et c’est en tout
cas la référence la plus importante de la
philosophie POLITIQUE. Platon imagine une
cité utopique dont le but est de réaliser
la justice, qu’il définit comme l’harmonie
des parties dans le tout. Sa cité atteint
l’harmonie sociale grâce à deux facteurs.
Elle divise tout d’abord les citoyens en 3
catégories : les gardiens (les gouvernants),
les auxiliaires (les guerriers) et les producteurs
(tous les autres). Ensuite, elle donne le
pouvoir à une élite de philosophes qui vivent
ensemble selon des principes communistes.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, allez
lire mon résumé détaillé sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
2ème référence : Le Prince, Machiavel
Cet ouvrage est à l’origine de ce qu’on
appelle le « machiavélisme », l’idée qu’il
faut exercer le pouvoir politique en excluant
les considérations morales. En effet, Machiavel
désenchante la politique en la débarrassant des
scrupules juridiques et moraux qui restreignaient,
voire paralysaient l’action de l’État au Moyen
Âge. Il rejette tout idéalisme parce qu’il pense
que les hommes sont des tyrans en puissance.
Il ne veut pas faire régner la justice,
mais seulement canaliser les intérêts
conflictuels pour qu’ils s’entre-détruisent
sans avoir pu ébranler le pouvoir. Cependant,
le machiavélisme dégénère en amoralisme : le
philosophe propose même un système généralisé
d’immoralité et d’illégalité.
3ème référence : Les Six livres
de la République, Jean Bodin
La théorie de l’État de Jean Bodin est une
des principales sources de la tradition
constitutionnelle française, et Les Six Livres
de la République sont un des premiers ouvrages
de philosophie politique des Temps modernes.
Le concept le plus important du livre est la
souveraineté de l’État. Comment caractériser la
souveraineté de l’État ? Par les droits régaliens
et par la reconnaissance internationale. Pour
Jean Bodin, qui défendait l’absolutisme royal,
la souveraineté de l’État doit être absolue :
elle n’est soumise à aucune règle, ni à aucun
contrat avec le corps social. Mais en pratique,
l’État doit être hiérarchisé pour la bonne
transmission verticale de l’autorité.
4ème référence : Léviathan, Thomas Hobbes
Cet ouvrage sert à justifier l’octroi d’une
puissance exceptionnelle à l’État. Hobbes
fait référence au Léviathan, un monstre marin
colossal capable d’anéantir le monde, parce
qu’il veut que l’État ait les moyens d’éteindre
l’extrême instabilité de l’état de nature. Cet
état de nature est une « guerre de tous contre
tous », où « l’homme est un loup pour l’homme
» DONC les hommes doivent passer un contrat pour
sortir de cette impasse. Ils créent ce faisant un
État illimité qui préserve la civilisation
de la violence originelle.
5ème référence : Du contrat social, Rousseau
C’est l’ouvrage de référence pour justifier le
principe de souveraineté du peuple. Rousseau
y refonde la société politique sur de toutes
nouvelles bases dans le but d’édifier un système
de pouvoir démocratique qui réussisse à garantir à
la fois l’égalité et la liberté des citoyens. Son
contrat social crée un corps moral et politique,
c’est-à-dire qu’en s’associant, les citoyens
forment un tout qui possède, à l’image d’un
individu, un « moi », une « vie » et une « volonté
», la volonté générale. En pratique, c’est grâce à
la loi que le peuple a le pouvoir. Chacun décide
en contribuant à élaborer la loi, et chacun reste
libre parce qu’il est soumis à une règle qu’il
a lui-même contribué à élaborer.
6ème référence : De l'esprit
des lois, Montesquieu
Comme le précédent, cet ouvrage a jeté les bases
philosophiques de la démocratie moderne. Ce qu’il
a d’original, c’est son pragmatisme : Montesquieu
réfléchit à l’efficacité des lois en dehors
de l’idéologie ou de la religion. À ses yeux,
il faut adapter les lois au régime politique,
au pays et au peuple auxquels elles
s’appliqueront. L’idée la plus célèbre
et la plus influente du livre est la séparation
des pouvoirs. Pour empêcher l’arbitraire et les
abus liés à l’exercice de missions souveraines,
il faut séparer et équilibrer le législatif,
l’exécutif, et le judiciaire — MAIS ces pouvoirs
peuvent tout de même interagir.
7ème référence : De la liberté
des Anciens comparée à celle
des Modernes, Benjamin Constant
Cette mémorable conférence donnée en 1819 est
une bonne référence pour justifier la protection
des libertés individuelles. Benjamin Constant
explique qu’il existe deux sortes de liberté. La
« liberté des Anciens » est la liberté politique
dont jouit l’individu lorsqu’il participe à
la vie publique. La « liberté des Modernes »,
en revanche, c’est la liberté civile qu’a
l’individu de jouir de ses droits et de
développer ses facultés comme bon lui semble,
tant qu’il ne nuit pas à autrui. Ces deux
conceptions sont en tension, notamment
lors de la Révolution française, où les
révolutionnaires ont voulu substituer la liberté
des Anciens à celle des Modernes.
8ème référence : De la démocratie en
Amérique, Alexis de Tocqueville
C’est l’ouvrage de référence pour parler des
caractéristiques de la société démocratique,
que Tocqueville a mises en lumière après un
voyage de presque un an aux États-Unis. La
première chose qui l’a frappé, c’est à quel point
l’égalité des conditions imprègne les mentalités.
Il note aussi que la démocratie américaine
donne le pouvoir à l’opinion publique. La
France et les États-Unis ont là un point commun
: l’opinion publique y est le pouvoir dominant,
en vertu de quoi la souveraineté du peuple
est une réalité de chaque jour. Cela engendre
cependant un grand conformisme, une certaine
« tyrannie de la majorité ».
9ème référence : Qu'est-ce qu'une
nation ?, Ernest Renan
Cette conférence de 1882 fixe les termes de la
conception française de la nation. Renan montre
que la nation est une innovation historique qui
repose en partie sur l’oubli. « France » est par
exemple devenu le nom du pays alors même qu’il
n’y était entré qu’une imperceptible minorité
de Francs. L’idée de la race ne permet pas de
déterminer les frontières d’une nation, car il
n’existe pas de race pure. Les bons critères, ce
sont l’appropriation de la mémoire collective et
le désir de vivre ensemble.
10ème référence : Le savant et le
politique, Max Weber
C’est l’ouvrage de référence
pour définir ce qu’est l’action politique. Max
Weber pose d’abord que l’État est le détenteur du
pouvoir politique dans les sociétés modernes. Dans
celles-ci, l’autorité politique est rationnelle,
parce qu’elle est fondée sur la croyance à la
légalité des ordonnances et à la légalité des
titres de ceux qui exercent la domination. Le
sociologue explique également dans cet ouvrage
qu’il existe deux états d’esprit différents
en politique : soit on agit pour atteindre
un certain résultat — c’est « l’éthique de
responsabilité » ; soit on agit pour préserver
ses valeurs — c’est « l’éthique de conviction
». Enfin, il explique aussi que le professionnel
de la politique vit DE la politique, tandis que
le militant vit POUR la politique.
11ème référence : L'étrange
défaite, Marc Bloch
Ce livre est l’analyse de référence sur la
débâcle française de 1940. Pour Marc Bloch,
c’est le pays tout entier qui était « malade »
d’un immobilisme généralisé. Les élites militaires
étaient les premiers responsables, parce
qu’elles ont manqué d’autorité, d’organisation,
et de capacité d’adaptation à la guerre moderne.
Mais c’est plus globalement l’esprit français,
cette intelligence nationale dont le pays
est si fier, qui est responsable de la
débâcle de 1940. L’historien voit dans les élites
françaises, engoncées dans leur esprit de caste,
formées dès l’enfance au bachotage, au
formalisme, à la bureaucratie, à la fidélité
aux doctrines apprises, et à la révérence envers
les puissants — il voit dans ces élites françaises
l’incarnation de la paralysie intellectuelle
responsable de l’étrange défaite.
12ème référence : Mémoires de
guerre, Charles de Gaulle
Cette référence est importante parce
qu’elle révèle la conception de la
France du fondateur de la Cinquième République.
Il y a d’abord, dans cette conception, une dose
de messianisme : Charles de Gaulle est persuadé
que la providence voue la France à la grandeur,
à un destin hors du commun, dans le succès
comme dans l’échec. Sur le plan politique,
il veut que la nation française soit unie, c’est
pourquoi il se méfie des intérêts particuliers,
des partis, et des idéologies. Sur le
plan géopolitique, il veut que la France
soit indépendante, ce qui justifie qu’elle soit
flexible pour défendre ses intérêts.
13ème référence : Les Deux Corps
du Roi, Ernst Kantorowicz
Cette référence sert à justifier la nécessaire
continuité du pouvoir politique et le consentement
à l’existence de l’État. Avec l’image
des deux corps du roi, l’historien Ernst
Kantorowicz distingue, d’une part, le corps
naturel et mortel du roi ; et d’autre part,
le corps mystique et immortel qui incarne le
royaume tout entier et en garantit la continuité
politique et spirituelle. La métaphore a évolué
jusqu’au XIIIe siècle, où le pouvoir de l’État
s’est institutionnalisé dans une administration.
L’État devient alors une personne fictive,
un corps mystique et universel, et il revendique
ce faisant une permanence jusque-là réservée à
l’Église et à l’Empire romain.
14ème référence : La Crise de la culture,
Hannah Arendt
Cet ouvrage est la référence
pour expliquer le fait que la tradition n’a plus
pour nous l’autorité qu’elle avait par le passé.
Quelles sont les causes de cette mutation ?
Hannah Arendt souligne tout d’abord que les
sociétés de consommation de masse transforment
la culture en biens de consommation forcément
éphémères — alors que la culture traditionnelle
est par définition DURABLE. Elle met aussi en
évidence la priorité donnée au divertissement,
qui désacralise l’objet culturel. À ses yeux, nous
devons retrouver un rapport approprié à la culture
pour sortir de l’impasse où nous sommes coincés,
entre le passé et l’avenir.
15ème référence : Démocratie et
Totalitarisme, Raymond Aron